what's up reject nation my name is Greg
Alba I'm John Humphrey we are going to
watch the trailer for Robert England's
Wow John just let me let me finish Jesus
Christ John the most impatient guy no
I'm just really excited Jesus John let
me talk what are we not just for this
White House official trailer Robert a
Iger Robert Englund is directing this
are Robert Pattinson Willem Dafoe oh we
got volcko and Batman that's exciting
stuff let's check this out
[Music]
take me once I'm timber back walk with
being a wiki just looking on living it's
like anywhere
start new on the run keep in secret so
he
[Music]
you
[Music]
ever
how long have we been on this rock
five weeks two days help me to recollect
oh yeah awesome
good old 824 awesome yeah so before we
hop into this discussion wanted to save
it for after the reaction download a
fault in the start a staff over there
buddy 30 second reaction reviews for
films TV shows and or trailers been
posting daily free to download free to
use you can post your own reactions as
well please do it today we would love it
we like attention you know it's funny
about this everything everything is so
funny if I guess there's Larry hilarious
I recently have been reading like
yesterday I took a lot of time out to
start reading this book from HP
Lovecraft called the shadow over
Innsmouth yeah which led me down a path
of just researching a lot of HP
Lovecraft material and this isn't based
off HP Lovecraft
but I'm like this seems so much like him
everything I was researching like
yesterday this is like a thousand
percent I was even looking for films I'm
working a little side project that was
looking for films I'm like looks like HP
Lovecraft inspired and somehow I have
Law of Attraction this trailer into my
life based off that just like the
psychological horror the oppressive
nature of it all some of the fish like
you know little you get hints of like
fish-like creatures inside of yeah I'm
really liking the aesthetic of it all
and I love the commitment to not just
having the black and white
cinematography but also even the audio
sounding that way and shooting it in the
frame ratio of a film like back that for
boundary yeah the entire all the
performances feel that way too of just
like the old-timey voiced and Willem
Dafoe is doing this wrong they just
wouldn't hear in a modern day take that
would just sound goofy now yeah yeah
really does feel like a movie kind of
ripped out of another time and I loved I
mean I really liked the witch and
obviously Robert Edgar's has a knack for
that kind of authentic period dialogue
authentic yeah and dressing and also
yeah just the capturing of this reminded
me of so many old silent movies and to
have these two guys isolated both as a
story device and also just for these
actors is really exciting to me
personally I hope this trailer at least
gets a lot of attention right now it's a
separate topic because Robert Pattinson
being cast as Batman oh this is totally
bad it's totally the kind of Batman
portrayal we're gonna get right I
haven't looked at any of the comments
but I'm sure there's some comments or
talk about that he's gonna connect at
the end it's gonna be like split
[Music]
well I'm thinking that when he was first
cast as Batman there's a lot of people
you know just immediately represent
Twilight and there were some people
myself included became whose defense
going but wait a minute he's done a lot
of great work outside of Twilight where
he shows he's a damn fine actor lazy
he's a great great freakin actor and
just in this trailer alone you can see a
lot of that caliber of talent and I'm
hoping that this film gets a lot of
attention it's not gonna be this is like
a B cinema school kind of film is they
gonna be like jump-scare the movie this
seems like it's gonna take its time and
be very much like what's the lifestyle
of two guys working in a light house all
alone on an island off of you know
Eastern America do any its allies very
just about like its atmosphere its whole
aura which I like the witch a hell of a
lot I know it wasn't for everybody no it
was mean avatar at the bar we've talked
a lot about this recently how there's
like two kinds of horror films you got
your conjuring kind of horror films
blockbuster horror yeah where it's like
funhouse jump scare fest or like child's
play and then you have you're
essentially you're a 24 yeah but this
looks different you know like I think a
lot of the kinds of more arthouse horror
flicks tend to be a little bit similar
in vein a little too often usually and
me lately yeah especially I think things
get popular certain types of stories get
very popular
I feel like babadook and hereditary were
like the capitol ones oh yeah and then
once those movies get huge you get a
bunch of like oh here's the
psychological situation explained
through some sort of horror metaphor
yeah the supernatural is it not is it
really about grief you know
hello brain but there's like a little
bit of what the hell is going on at the
very but this looks entirely different
its engrossing yeah this feels like a
kind of movie that you can only
appreciate in a theater because you
would have to be immersed into this sort
of experience of the right audio and the
right
you know and this looks like a 40 X
experience yeah get the water and go in
the entire movie yeah there's always a
rise on a rail but yeah you know
occasionally they'll have that big light
go by get on actually you know it's not
a bad idea they would never do it I
don't like if they're it won't work if
there's one technological advancement I
could pioneer for cinema it's like the
gradually immersive 4d eggs like subtle
40 it would be cool well on Rotten
Tomatoes right now the film holds a 98
percent based on 52 reviews man that is
really positive that's so that's an
early buzz if I ever heard really early
buzz well guys are you excited for a
lighthouse why don't you leave a comment
down below let us know what you think
about it are you excited for the
cinematic crossover of DC characters
yeah to be joining this picture what's
your favorite HP Lovecraft
oh yeah oh definitely yeah seems like
some Elder Gods are lurking just around
that bend or behind some cloud or
something I don't know how to pronounce
that name woofer is like boys world [ __ ]
- oh I mean I've read it all the time
I'm like what is this work there is a
complicated like the recording of how
you're supposed to say the short answer
is Kalulu dad but I think most lay
persons just say kethu yeah I don't know
what the well before I wrap this up I
would also like to give a page from the
day shout out to John who do you think
we should give it to this time around we
got a few people left let's give it to
Jen Smith Jen Smith and Jen in the
hologram out of the people left to give
shout outs to for this month you're the
one who talks with rhythm Jose Shawn
take it away
Jenny keep personal try not to make it
only about you last half of this it's
not got anything to do with me Jen's my
TV buddy cuz she's got great taste and
you know what I'm thinking Jen and the
Holograms needs to be a real thing you
need to self-fund your own comic book
about you starting your own rock band so
that eventually
that can get made into a movie that
everyone will hate and complain that it
wasn't true enough to the source
material thank you so much for watching
shows with me and for feeding back and
even just for commenting on other stuff
because it's not just me so yeah love
your presence here and I hope that one
day we could meet at a light house you
know in the middle of have you ever been
a rainstorm I've been near one I've
never been inside of one I feel like it
would be a draftee experience it is so
cool in there really like physically
colder like I met up with many strange
men there Oh whose faces I have never
seen that's good that's it's good to
meet strange men in in just a giant
phallic symbols yeah I have had some
real itchy situation since but it's been
worth it I've creams for you my friend